und zwar weil ich endlich schau machen
wo ich eure
bitte was hey leute und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge
megaprojekt ich komme gerade vom
training und habe daher meine haare
nicht gemacht die stehen jetzt einfach
in die arbeit ist es relativ egal ich
habe gedacht ich mach mit cam weil ich
wollte euch ein paar kommentare in
dieser folge durch lesen wir gehen jetzt
auf den server ich verstehe ja so ein
bisschen am pegel das ist einigermaßen
klappt aber es müsste jetzt klappen
ich werde sehr ruhig bleiben folge 100
ist jetzt vorbei denn witzig war es als
am anfang die hoch kam war gab es
erstmal so 20 daumen runter das gab es
fünf daumen hoch oder so und es gab
zwischenzeitlich auch mal 700 daumen
runter mittlerweile ist nur noch 500 das
heißt nur noch es immer noch viel
obwohl es halten trolle sich glaubt
viele habe ich damit deswegen echten
abonniert ich bin gespannt auf die
statistiken weil ich nehmen dass er
gerade auf kurz nachdem die folge online
gegangen ist
selbst kurz danach drei stunden später
ist gerade jedoch ganz genau drei
stunden gerade 23 uhr am 4
jedenfalls sind die reaktion so
unterschiedlich die einen meinen endlich
dritter raus aus dem megaprojekt haben
das video nicht zu ende geguckt habe ich
dann so höhe der strafgelder zu ja ich
bin nicht wechsel nach dem motto immer
noch so ein bisschen in diesem troll
glauben zu bleiben ist eigentlich einer
drauf nehmen sind umgestellt dann haben
auch eine menge leute geschrieben
aber man dachte du trittst wirklich aus
also viele habe ich keinen bock auf das
megaprojekt irgendwie weil eine gemeinde
als mega park entwickelt sich zum himmel
projekt aber lassen nicht die kommentare
die ich heute heute durchgehend will
sondern ich wollte eigentlich eine show
irgendwann mal hier auf meinem kanal
machen die ich kann dies komme schon
ende
allerdings werde ich sowas in der
richtung auf meinem neuen reallife kanal
machen luca filmt link ist immer in der
beschreibung hat dürft ihr gerne
draufklicken war bestätigt es scheiße
eigentlich bei mir wird verstehe ich
nicht ob die stelle zu rewe
jedenfalls auf youtube.com / luca films
hatte youtube das fragen mich immer noch
leute hey luca wieso kommt hier nicht
die real life mehr was meinst du da so
dass der kanal den könnt ihr alle
abonnieren und zwar kommt da jetzt nur
noch real videos von mir also hier
kommen nur noch mit kamm und minecraft
jedenfalls hab ich muss mal kurz in der
ju metaphern gucken ich habe die kiste
schon umgetauscht ja gut weil die kiste
war voll also es läuft auf jeden fall
bei uns
vivendi scrap boxen rausgeschmissen am
laufenden band management
ich kann mir eigentlich noch eines
verriet peter baumann häufig doppelt so
viel passiert die man das denn und zwar
weil ich endlich schau machen wo ich
eure
bitte was
lena war das den trampolin habe ich nur
bei dehner gesehen
diese elendige alter da baute mir
einfach ein trampolin rennen okay
natürlich ich habe trampolin obwohl ich
das nicht mal gemacht habe naja ich
fliege dass er fragt mich ob ich dachte
mein bett verriet explodiert weil
irgendwie scrapbook so viel rein getan
aber irgendwie sowas aber natürlich
wobei simon steht wieder alles im
dingsda helfen war dem simon jemand ein
bisschen die kiste sind ja sozial kommen
dahin
du kommst dahin du kommst du mich
verarschen perfekt jetzt seht euch das
rein wie das jetzt voll gefüllt wird
jedenfalls wollte ich eine show machen
wo okay sie ist voll
natürlich
das war nicht meine absicht ich mache
das einfach per hand jetzt hier rein
ob man da will man einer der alles voll
ich kann das nicht so rein tun das ist
alles voll scheiße wenn ich das hier
liegen lassen auch noch nicht wollte nur
helfen
ja ich habe ihm ein bisschen was
gerettet ich behalte das jetzt einfach
daneben geflogen das ist jetzt nicht
böse oder so sorry man wenn du das
siehst und ich habe spass text genommen
aber ich habe dir da schon wieder
zurückholen und wenn die alte lebendig
elendig im rohr stecken geblieben
jedenfalls aachen wollte ich einen baum
luca kommt zurück auf den punkt ich bin
auf dem weg und zwar weil ich da so
kommentare vorstellen die untermain
videos sind oder bei anderen videos
allerdings wo ich mir drin wenn uns was
alles war so ein bisschen super
kommentare raussuchen und so zeigen
nicht wie dumm manche leute sind sondern
auch mal so ein paar witzige kommentare
jedenfalls würde ich sagen was ihr
direkt anfangen und zwar unter epic jump
web hat irgendwie wollte das noch was
machen
achja ist jetzt an dem mfs oder muss ich
eine menge für kräften moment wie viele
brauche ich davon 666 und zwar hat da
jemand runter geschenk komme ist cool
und kontrast das auch nicht so scheiße
ich weiß nicht ich liebe solche stimmen
kommentare die die leute glaube ich
nicht mal stumpf meinen es erscheint die
wii einfach nur so wissen einfach so
dahin geschrieben und ich weiß nicht wer
so was irgendwie ich feiere das gibt mir
sechs energy krstic nächster kommentar
ich habe dir vor längerer zeit schon
rausgesucht nicht mehr die hier schon
angucke dann muss ich schon lachen steht
so
es hat bei mir jemand halt da oben das
electric ranch geklappt oben also hier
nur electric band geklaut und alle haben
sie geschrieben den er war dass lina
walter so gefragt weil das und schreib
zu einer ich bin echt unglaublich
scheiße gerade im aussehen kann ich das
nicht irgendwie so ein bisschen richten
oder so wenn ich nicht was drin ist ist
ja nur fahrtwind schreibt er unter den
ersten fünf ist gefährlich weil einfach
für jeden scheiß die eisbrocken kämpfens
gefängnis ist mittlerweile so ein
running gag was richtig geil war ich ja
ja das klappt so liebt davon habe ich
nicht mehr so viel einstecken ist denke
ich reichen nächster kapitals ich hab
nur acht rausgesucht ich wollte einfach
viel mehr aussuchen aber ich dachte
jetzt da ich jetzt auf luca filme serien
mache wo die frage heißt sie glaube ich
warte warte warte nein
sie hatte einen anderen namen und zwar
bestehen namen mein handy drin
lucas leiva ecke genauso wollte ich das
denn da könnt ihr mir fragen stellen und
deswegen dachte jetzt dass ich dir jetzt
so vorstelle
jedenfalls aber auch unter anderem ich
brauchte das ist ein elektronik sorgen
dass das land waren circle ok hat was
war das hier anfangs maschinen blog
daran kann ich mich erst mal setzen und
ist meint auch welche moment ich lasse
das ich kann nicht mehr schienen blogger
kindern habe ich doch noch hier und ist
meinte auch noch einer wem liebste
konrad dem lieb zu konrad mit konrad
also drei rechtschreibfehler oder noch
mehr in drei wörtern und dann ist es
nach sonne private frage und ich habe
eine freundin und ich weiß nicht also
das ist ich finde dass ist so privat
deswegen möchte ich auch freundin von
youtube trennen weil weiß nicht ich
finde es in vitro irgendwie allem videos
mit den freunden machen
kriegen wieder milliarden klicks drauf
oder so ich finde das ist privates
sollte man auch trennen nächster
kommentar beule spongebob ist einfach
wenn ihr den alter bäume rap gegen dna
gewinnen habe dann feiert er den
kommentar bestimmt genauso wie ich weil
es ist schon hart weil sie nicht finde
ich mega nahles alter beutel ihre dna
auch dieses apfelschorle gehen wenn er
wasser weil sie nicht feierlich
irgendwie und dann einfach so leiter
beutelsbach spaß ich lache über scheiße
ich weiß ich weiß
mach ich das rad richtig lief ein teil
brauche ich und ich brauche ich habe
nicht so viel kopper cable wie ich
eigentlich brauche scheiße alte kino
drei stück raus für brauche ich dann
acht auf zwölf auch man jetzt muss ich
erst wieder diese kg hier mit freunden
du nur 11
als wieso habe ich denn das kann nicht
sein dass ich so wenig rabatt nur oder
wenn es sein wie sie es hier drin warum
in gottes namen echt traurig schade ich
dachte ich wäre so keller
organisiert und so kommen dann kann ich
jetzt nicht in die mit you meter machen
das csm anwalt rezepte es echt hält
camouflage kofler das jetzt mal ein
bisschen was raus wir haben ja ein
bisschen was ne
ok natürlich war eventuell bisschen viel
egal ich muss jetzt eigentlich nur
warten egal ich kann ich noch ein
kommentar vorlesen wahrscheinlich
weilheimer mit seinen kollegen feiern
und alle geschichten sind an einem abend
geschah entstanden etwa schreibt
geschehen war using a lp traders mädchen
ich nenne es trotzdem ist es trotzdem
nicht in denen mein kopf wie spielen
dabei schule wieder los war dann zwar
das unter der folge wahr oder falsch wo
manuell von drei stories die von zwei
stories zweimal am anfang so sagt er ja
ich war mit meinen kollegen feiern
die alte untergestell wahrscheinlich war
und derzeit mega oft der jetzt von den
insgesamt acht folgen die wir hatten
sind achtmal zwei sind 16 geschichte
wenn man von 13 dass das 17 geschichten
und locker zehn mal gesagt am anfang ich
war mit kollegen vor
sie kommentiert einfach so ganz weiß
wahrscheinlich bei einmal in seinem
leben mit seinen kollegen gefeiert und
da sind alle geschichten an einem abend
entstanden so richtig freche einfach nur
hier kommt jetzt hier mit 339 menschen
müsse doch jetzt zeigen was anderes
brauche gebiet würden daher auch nicht
jetzt hab ich nur sieben alter fällt auf
und habe ich noch mehr von diesem plan
estimate krams wie kriege ich das denn
noch hin
apa ich bin echt zu blöd ich weiß ich
weiß damals wusste ich koche cable
rezept und ständig älter auch kopper er
höre klingt logisch
sorry jungs hat man gemerkt hab ich habe
sogar ganz viel koffer alter geilich
copper corp kopf ich mal so viel ich
kann ich klopfe was anderes braucht man
koffer gar nicht oder ja ich hab genug
und ich mache das so mehr als man
bräuchte ich nicht nach münchen
ich weiß gar nicht gekannt der monsters
nebenbei wird nicht verarschen
denn hier hat dein maul halten und
nervig dein maul habe ich geträumt in
conny state construction die meinung
auch so geteilt was wollt ihr denn jetzt
alle die meisten meinten wirklich ist es
ja schon über 10.000 likes momenten
meist meinten halt einfach so ya konan
ya neue folge so allerdings dann auch
wieder leute nur gestellt also wenn ich
was hochladen dann ist es nicht gestellt
auch wenn ich lache oder so ich mag so
dass einfach nicht ich hasse so
gespielte comedy alter kein morgen
dieses pony dass trotzdem alle acht die
tus auf der mensch da kann ich natürlich
durchkommt ich hab sogar noch mehr block
noch eine mini um sterbe kann ich nicht
aufnehmen
du kommst da auch mit reinem gewissen
bei allen ich will eigentlich nicht so
lange auf einem sofa 14 minuten wo ich
möchte den versuch auf jeden fall noch
fertig kriegen so das mache ich mal eben
hier
moment ich mache das einfach mal hier
wie sich nutzen ihm einen project table
alter und ich brauche ich und ich liebe
euch redstone die kinder warum zu stein
am rhein sowie so und so
als das geklappt asche sei das alles weg
natürlich die sechs kristalle die sich
auf klaren deswegen den block habe ich
und waren zwar geht ist normaler tag für
redstone zwei glos doch zwei love is
here at dann zwei glos den etat der
miet24 redstone ich bin da kommen wir so
was nie mehr 2 ich habe jetzt nicht gut
ja sorry ich verwechsle die beiden
sachen immer so und in die mitte kommt
den denker stammt firma die darin kommt
statt
da kommt dann und hans mesch einen blog
so soll wollte schirmer paar kommentare
hören
hat jemand geschrieben die kommentare
vol schieße chrome
ich habe in dem video über chrome
gelästert weil das bei mir manchmal
sagen haken ist und dann hat er darunter
geschrieben entweder er meinte voll
scheiße komme chrome also bis voll
scheiße oder er meinte wolle scheiße
komm her so nach dem motto oder meinte
voll scheiße com
ich weiß es nicht ich konnte nicht
verwandt leon wieder zurück in die
schule
andere kommt er conny rasiere ich mal
ich weiß nicht wie man das durch die cam
erkennen will habe ich mich rasiere oder
nicht aber ich bin rasiert ich rasiere
mich alle zwei drei tage
von daher ich weiß nicht wie das
erkennen bitte auch habe ich gerade
gelesen und teil 100 dummes kind andere
youtuber wollen auch noch auf dem server
spielen das ist wider denn so ein
kandidat der das video halt dann mal
nicht zu ende geguckt hat auch mal wird
sie sich leute dena hat mir meine
elektrisch einfach mal nicht
zurückgegeben auch geil von ihm ohne
witz ich glaube ich brauche einfach sein
personal trader
in den blöcken blackjack einfach nur
kurz irgendeinen anderen aus weil sonst
ich möchte jetzt meinen images anfällig
kriegen halte und ich traue mich nicht
einfach so jetzt abzubauen da denke ich
mir das ist hier von anders geworden
alles mit sich mehr geschadet als er
durfte gleich wollte den werkzeugen
blöcke sind werkzeuge oder blah blah
blah blah hat der entwickelt die so
klaut mir den die auch einfach man ist
es ärgerlich
nein nein ich schaue wie man sich an
macht das packe von denen man auf der
seite von demi jetzt klaut er sich
einfach dass auch das will ich ja gut
das kann ich auch selber machen
dieses rad die wahl bei manchen stellen
in der stadt zu 15 menschen mussten
karten machen
jetzt machen wir hier power crafting
so rentsch bronze und chemiebranche wo
ich denn doch dann änderte sich als ob
ich keinen bronze ab
und scheiß man nicht kennt bronze
natürlich hat rezepte
ach naja das ist jetzt nicht mal gesagt
google.com escada werde in der nächsten
folge eine feste aufstellen und mir eine
ranch kräften und ja das wasser erst mal
mit den kommentaren jetzt euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich über einen daumen
hoch freuen
mein reallife kanal stellenbeschreibung
wehrreform ihr sehen wollt dann könnt
ihr einfach abonnieren
abgaben wordsworth strecken von meiner
zeit mich jetzt aufgenommen hat sind
schon wieder 2 6 kilometer dazugekommen
das feuer war und sonst wenig sagen
schreib mir eure meinung vernünftig in
die kommentare zufolge 100 jetzt noch
mal dass wir da ein bisschen darüber
diskutieren können ob ihr sowas gut fall
weil ich hab seit einziger nicht
wirklich umgesetzt mit denen muss man
einfach nicht meine sache eigentlich das
beste
wir sehen uns dann eventuell in einer
ersten folgen wider